So far,
we've used the loadContainerPreferFresh
method to load the container.
And this takes the containerID,
which you get from the TagManager UI,
and the defaultContainer.
So this method checks if
the app has a container
that's been refreshed in
the past 12 hours or so.
And if it does,
then we load the container.
And if there isn't a fresh container,
then load a new one over the network.
And if there's a timeout or
a network error before the container
finishes loading, then the container
holder status is set to unsuccessful.
There are a couple of other methods for
loading the container,
loadContainerDefaultOnly, which will
only get the default container,
and then there's also
loadContainerPreferNonDefault.
So this one prefers to not
use the default container but
doesn't necessarily look for
a fresh container.
To get the freshest value,
use loadContainerPreferFresh.
But fresh is a relative term.
If we look at the reference page for
TagManager, it says that the mobile app
refreshes a container from
the network every 12 hours.
So one of the benefits of
TagManager is that non-developers
cannot put changes to an app.
And these will often be bulk
uploads of many values.
This mechanism is not really meant for
second-by-second changes, but
it's nice to see the changes
when we're developing our app.
And that's why we added the call
to manually refresh the container.
Here's the reference,
the refresh method on the container.
And it says, in order to limit
the frequency of network communication,
refresh method is throttled, and
that you're supposed to wait at least 15
minutes before calling
this method again.
So even manual refreshes are not
guaranteed to take effect
more than about every 15 minutes.
I've had good luck with my changes
taking effect very quickly
when I change variable values in
TagManager, but it's not guaranteed.
If you don't see the changes
taking effect immediately,
don't be too surprised.